ukraine's counterattack in the south and
east of the country has put russian
forces on the defensive
keefe says it has liberated dozens of
communities but as its troops advance
they find new devastation and new
evidence of russian atrocities
just three days ago this village in the
harkeev region was under russian control
now it's back in ukrainian hands
but signs of its recent occupation are
everywhere
including evidence of more potential
russian war crimes against civilians in
the area where heavy fighting took place
early in the invasion
the investigators are working on the
site and have inspected it and exhumed
the bodies of two people
the people had gunshot wounds to the
back of the head and their ears were cut
off
the village is just one of dozens kyiv
says it's taken back within the last
week
as of today the armed forces of ukraine
have liberated and taken control of more
than 30 settlements in the hakeem region
in some villages security and safety
checks are ongoing
we're gradually taking control of new
settlements
everywhere we return the ukrainian flag
and safety to our people
moscow has said little about ukraine's
seemingly rapid advances in the
northeast
but its top official in the harkiev
region admitted on russian state tv on
friday that keeve had scored a
significant victory
with russia rushing reinforcements to
the region
there's likely yet more fierce fighting
ahead
and for more on this let's cross
straight to dw correspondent nick
connolly in kiev nick so we've been
hearing that ukraine's been having some
success in the northeast what more can
you tell us
well indeed in just the last hour
there'd been reports in ukraine media
that ukrainian forces are now taking the
strategic town of kupensk it's not fully
confirmed yet but we have seen pictures
on social media of rush of ukrainian
troops rather in front of the town hall
there and that is a long way away from
the previous positions from the previous
towns that ukraine had taken in recent
days uh dozens of kilometers so it
really does seem like ukrainian forces
are making very fast progress this
against situation where in donbass
russia has been taking a couple of
hundred metres at best every couple of
days so a real contrast there in a sense
that the ukrainians have caught the
russians off guard all the talk in
previous weeks and months was about the
south about kerason uh and maybe that
was a distraction tactic to get rush to
focus its efforts there it seems like
lots of the troops in this part of
ukraine on the russian side were
immobilized from luhansk nets these
weren't regular army units these were
people often in their 40s 50s with no
military experience and very poor
equipment and ones who obviously are not
in a situation not in
any kind of shape to stand up to this uh
ukrainian advance um it is now seemingly
the case that ukraine is looking to
encircle a large number of russian
troops in the city of izum uh and their
retreat would be quite difficult given
the geography given some rivers in the
way and bridges that are very vulnerable
to attack so a sense here in ukraine
that the army is on a roll and that
there is the potential to take lots and
lots of russian prisons of war now the
details are all very very light right
now the ukrainian army has basically put
a kind of media embargo out so this is
all based on social media from the front
lines from people who live there and
from russian bloggers but it does seem
that this is going better than anyone
here in kiev really could have expected
okay so good news for uh key for the
ukrainian army but a worrying news from
the zaparisia nuclear power plant the
situation there seems to be getting
worse what more can you tell us
well definitely this is a very dangerous
situation this is europe's biggest
nuclear plant one of the biggest in the
world that is now cut off from outside
power supply there's only one of the six
reactors still on and that's basically
just operational at a low level to keep
the plant going to keep the cooling
going this is the big risk all the
experts talking about the risk of a
direct hit by arturi fire is obviously
there but that is they say less
of a real threat because these power
plants are quite well protected in terms
of the structure the real risk they say
the most likely risk
is a lack of power a lack of ability to
cool the reactors that could really lead
to some very dangerous situations if
that last reactor is shut down they'll
be totally dependent on diesel
generators to keep the cooling going and
in a situation where this is basically a
huge power station on the front lines
with daily shelling getting in enough
diesel to keep that cooling going is
going to be very very difficult the city
around it where the people who operate
the station live is without power
without water so the situation desperate
for the people still working there under
russian occupation we've heard in recent
days from top ukrainian officials that
they say the russians uh have been
abusing the staff there talk of staff
going missing being killed being
tortured so a very difficult situation
for the people trying to keep the
situation safe there now six months into
this occupation
very worrying indeed look nick a quick
last question if i made the german
foreign minister we understand returned
to keeve
this morning for a second visit since
the beginning of war of the war the
relations are a lot warmer since a few
months back are they not and so what
changed
well germany has finally come good on
some of the promises in terms of
supplying weapons the
anti-aircraft tanks the guipard tanks
have arrived some radar systems have
arrived some anti-aircraft systems are
expected to arrive in the coming weeks
but it's pretty thin in terms of new
promises in the pipeline of further
supplies i think analina berbock the
green party foreign minister is a very
welcome guest here in kiev her party has
been very outspoken in its support for
ukraine and for supplying more weapons
the situation is a bit more difficult
with the social democrats of chancellor
schultz who've been a lot more reluctant
to
promise and to help ukraine militarily
so i think there's that kind of
coalition difficulty there the greens
alone don't get to decide what germany
does but definitely things are a bit
better and there's a lot less in the way
of open criticism from the ukrainian
side
okay dw correspondent nick connolly in
key reporting for us